- Once I remove the battery,
I can safely disconnect the cables,
and we can get started on
the battery replacement.
- Every iPhone battery is going to expire.
That is, it's going to go bad over time
for some pretty technical reasons.
So a few months ago,
I shared that my iPhone 14 Pro's battery
had depleted faster than
my previous iPhones.
- Joanna Stern actually mentioned
that hers is down to 88% capacity.
- [Reporter] Wall Street
Journalist Joanna Stern
said her iPhone 14 Pro is down to 88%.
- And I shared some hidden
numbers about its battery health.
As of today, as the battery
hits 494 charge cycles,
the battery health is at 87%.
But what the heck do those numbers mean?
Where can you find them?
And why did this battery
deplete so fast in just a year?
I found the answers to
all of that and more.
There's no such thing
as a lithium ion battery
that lasts forever.
So Apple lets you know just
how healthy your battery is
in the software.
Go to Settings, Battery,
Battery Health, and Charging.
See that maximum capacity?
That's a measure of the
battery capacity relative
to when it was new.
When I first unboxed this iPhone 14 Pro,
it was at 100%.
Now, a year later, it's at 87%.
Yes, as that number gets lower,
the battery doesn't hold a charge as long.
Think of it like a shrinking gas tank,
and it's when that number gets
into the low 80% range
that you start to worry.
According to Apple's website,
a normal battery is
designed to retain up to 80%
of its original capacity at
500 complete charge cycles
when operating under normal conditions.
But what's a charge cycle?
(upbeat music)
Safety first.
Obviously, I got a
bicycle to explain cycles.
There we go.
All right, 500 cycles.
One, two.
How's this working?
Okay, let's pretend this
wheel is your battery.
You complete one charge
cycle when the battery goes
from 100% to 0%.
It's basically like the Tour de France.
But you don't complete a
cycle every time you charge.
Say you use 80% of your battery one day,
and then recharge it to 100% overnight.
If you use 20% the next day,
you will have discharged a total of 100%.
So yes, it could take multiple
days to complete one cycle.
That lithium ion battery in your phone
is rated for 500 of these cycles.
Anyone have a snack?
Nearing 400 cycles.
Thank you.
This is how they do it.
450.
And as you get closer to 500 cycles,
the more that battery capacity
percentage is gonna go down.
And yes, the battery will
drain faster when you use it.
And 500.
Why is it getting so slow?
Why is is it so hard to pedal?
How do you find out the
number of charge cycles
on your phone?
Well, the new iPhone 15
models actually show it.
Go to Settings, General, About,
then scroll down to Cycle Count.
For other iPhones,
you can download this
software called coconutBattery
to your Mac.
When you plug in your phone,
it will show the cycle count,
which brings me back to my iPhone 14 Pro.
I had hit 494 charge cycles in a year,
which makes me seem like
a total phone addict,
which, obviously, I am not,
but I don't think I use the phone
that much more than my iPhone 12 Pro,
which after two years of
use had 652 charging cycles
and 88% battery health.
But I had two leading theories
about why the 14 expired quicker.
Number one, software.
Some app or some part of
iOS was causing the battery
to drain faster.
Thus, I was charging it more,
so more cycle counts happened.
It's gonna hurt tomorrow.
Number two, heat.
I did a previous video on this,
but heat is the number
one enemy of batteries.
- Oh no, it's smoking.
- Okay, yeah, it is.
It is.
So maybe something inside
my phone was getting warm
or causing the battery to fail quicker.
When I took it to an Apple store,
I was told there was no hardware issue.
An Apple spokesman pointed me
to the company's website,
and said that given the cycles,
my battery's performance was
in line with what's promised.
Okay, so this battery expired quicker,
but it will happen to all
iPhone batteries eventually,
which brings us to two choices.
Buy a new iPhone, or replace your battery,
which is gonna be a lot cheaper
and better for the environment.
So I went to a local New
York City repair shop
to explore the replacement options.
How many battery replacements
would you say you do?
- Battery replacements are actually
one of our most common repairs,
especially on Apple devices.
I would say we get a
few devices every day,
even though it's a common misconception
that the battery can't be
replaced because, you know,
back in the day, we used
to just pop the back open,
replace the battery with
something we found online,
and that was it.
The batteries are actually
very easily replaceable,
usually takes about 15 to 20 minutes
- [Joanna] But not all battery
replacements are equal.
Joe here offers two options.
- So the battery we have here on the left
would be the Apple original
versus an aftermarket battery,
which we purchase from suppliers
that produce them for shops like us.
- [Joanna] Those aftermarket
or third-party batteries tend
to work as well according to Joe,
but you will get the following
message on the phone.
- That basically tells you
that it's unable to determine
if your iPhone battery
is a genuine Apple part,
and it tells you to go to Settings
to get more information about it.
- You can dismiss that initial popup,
but it will still show in Settings.
Plus, you won't be able to see
all that battery health information.
An Apple spokesman pointed me
to a report citing a study by the UL,
saying that in tests,
third-party batteries
overwhelmingly failed
to meet safety standards.
Joe says he buys safe,
high-quality batteries.
The easiest way to avoid the error message
is to get your battery
swapped at an Apple store,
or an Apple-authorized repair shop.
And honestly, it might cost about the same
to do it there too.
Joe said it would cost $89
for the iPhone 14 Pro battery
replacement at his store.
The Apple store quotes $99.
Why should I opt to come here?
- The Apple's warranty
is a 90-day warranty
on the batteries.
We offer a six-month warranty.
We also are able to replace
the battery within 10
to 20 minutes,
versus Apple's lengthy process,
sometimes can take an hour,
sometimes two or three
depending on how busy they are.
- So what did we learn here today?
Well, if you don't want
your battery to go bad,
don't charge your phone.
Seriously though,
you can keep those charge
cycles down by reducing use.
Relying on low power mode will help too.
There's also a new
setting on the iPhone 15
that will stop charging
at 80% to preserve health,
and definitely keep your
phone out of the heat,
but you can't live your
life babying your battery.
It's like, I guess we'll
just be sitting here,
preservin' charge cycles.
Great.
(upbeat music)
(Joanna sighs)
(Joanna exhales)